It flopped in theaters. It barely made sense.
The first three times you watched it,
but if you're a film nerd of a certain age or a very, with a dark side,
then you love Donnie Darko.
We visit the Colt classic. You watched on DVD.
So dudes would stop saying way you've never seen Donnie Darko than corner you.
While they try to explain it in this field,
they gave millennials their first taste of art house,
weirdness their first crush on Agilon hall and their first awakening slash
confirmation of their inner mall. God, they don't play it.
Cool because it came out 20 years ago. We all have an inner mall. Goth
me, Donnie Darko, a name so cool.
You got to say the whole thing every time. Donnie Darko, Donnie Darko,
Donnie Darko, Donnie Darko. What was his name? Donny.
Donny like most teenagers. He thinks he's a misunderstood genius.
Your Iowa test scores are intimidating. tiny. Why?
Why do you got to get so smart on us? Who's so special.
The fate of the entire world revolves around his choices,
but unlike every other teenager, he's right.
Cause Donny doesn't just blow grumps minds with his knowledge bomb can just lump
things into two categories. Things aren't that simple.
He's also a superhero stuck in a parallel universe who needs to send a duplicate
jet engine back in time through a portal with the power of telekinesis or
reality is doomed. Okay. So none of that is shown in the movie per se,
but if you watch the director's cut and pause it during the excerpts from the
philosophy of time travel, it's pretty obvious that anyway, wait,
where are you going? Come on.
They don't want to go back to my dorm and listen to that mad world song.
I've got more theories return to the eighties,
but not in an annoying stranger things kind of way.
Just a bunch of timely Michael Dukakis references. I'm voting for new caucus.
You want to say things Michael Dukakis will provide for this country to you
ready to squeeze one out.
But I want to be a president of the United States and thrill when bugs bunny on
ketamine arrives to give Donnie 28 days to save the world.
[inaudible] then like most kids,
his age waits until the last six hours to do anything about it.
Time is running out. We got to come to fulfill his destiny.
He'll need help from Patrick Swayze trying his hardest to make you not like him.
Does that. All the gusta you can muster. I said, good morning.
Firefighters discovered what has been referred to as a kitty corn done.
Okay, fine. This messy English teacher who loves drama.
Sit next to the boy. You think is the cutest.
This school girlfriend who falls asleep at the beginning of evil dead.
That's a deal breaker fellows and Seth Rogen before he'd smoked the edges of his
personality. Then your dad like stab your mom.
This is really hard to watch. I like your boots, huh? It's horrible.
Get them in a dab fast. Oh, that's better.
So bust out your skeleton shirt and throw on some tears for fears for the
ultimate Colt classic, they got buried. Cause October,
2001 was a bad time to release an airplane crash movie,
but it's so unique and open-ended,
you can go deeper into your own theories with every rewatch until you finally
grow out of it and take on the real challenge. Making sense of the creators.
Other big movie.
[Inaudible].
Now this is deep story.
Donald glower.
[Inaudible].
Malone in the dark ratio as Darko
origins, Patrick shady never been dismissed.
Put the Bonnie back in the box, nothing but respect for my president.
[inaudible] she's a care in queen cuties available now on
Netflix, Beavis and Butthead.
When the edible heads and the comments,
when we get something wrong in an honest trailer.
Papa Smurf didn't create Smurfette Gargamel did.
She was sent in as Gargamel evil spy,
but the overwhelming goodness of the Smurf way of life transformed as for the
whole gang-bang scenario, I just was so illogical, you know, Mercer,
asexual. They don't even have, what's the point of living reproductive organs.
If you don't have, it's just going to happen.
28 Days later. You know,
if you want to talk to a cute girl in your class,
don't listen to the evil bunny when he tells you to flood the school.
So you can walk home together. You can just say hi,
want to know how Marvel movies get made.
Watch our three-part series on everything it takes to make a blockbuster
actually happen. Luke, I'm a paid actor, David prose,
uh, again,
really wacky waving inflatable harmfully linked to bad wacky waving a fleet of
alarm playlists too bad wacky waving inflatable arm, flailing tube, man.